who were told by defense sources that a
senior U.S general said to you that the
British army is no longer regarded as a
tier one force how do you respond to
that well look first of all I've been
very clear for a number of years now as
defense secretary that the British army
has fallen behind its peer group and
needed investment and that's why Boris
Johnson in 2020 gave us a record
settlement supported by Rishi when he
was Chancellor of 16 billion pounds
extra in order to invest in our army and
we're starting to do that right now and
as I give you this interview there are
people making armored vehicles in
Telford and tanks and all sorts of
things which are the result of that
investment now clearly there are people
inside the building and across defense
that are very worried about the current
hollowing out of the army yes you have a
plan for modernization but they say it
will not deliver fast enough because the
threat is now and you need more money
faster what are you going to do about it
well firstly it's not the currently
hollowing out eventually holiday under
labor and conservative something like 20
30 years I was serving the Armed Forces
when that hollowing was going out it was
that long ago this is the point that you
know the music starts to stop the
direction of travel changes we've had a
very predominantly peaceful and stable
world for the last 20 years that is not
the case anymore Russia is you know
inflicting a war on Europe in Europe
against Ukraine the rise of China the
tensions in the Pacific radicalization
across Africa the world is becoming more
unstable and more insecure and I think
that's why you know the prime minister
at the time in 2020 enrichi recognizes a
requirement to meet that new threat but
it's not a new thing hollowing out what
we're seeing now is the consequences of
following ad and you know as a defense
secretary I've always said I'm not going
to pretend things are perfect I'm not
going to sort of say look over here look
at the red arrows and shoot me the color
I'm going to actually say that's what's
going on behind the scenes and we're
going to try and fix it and I would
rather have a perfectly formed properly
protected men and women of the Armed
Forces offer size we can afford and an
ambition we can afford then Pretend
We're somehow you know reaching Beyond
ourselves
just said that the Army needs urgent
recapitalization that the PM gets it and
a budget is coming what does he mean by
that well it does need urgent
recapitalization and that's why we're
investing it we're investing 34 billion
pounds in the Army's equipment plan
between now and 20 33. that's new
helicopters that is new tanks neon
personal cars new electronic warfare in
a whole range of of Suite to modernize
the fleet something that didn't happen
in my day and I think it's really really
important that the public understand we
are doing it now the criticism about it
needs to happen now is these things
don't happen now there's no magic one
there's no factories wearing away like
like car factories that you just press
buttons and out they come there are only
about two countries on the earth that
can sustain almost constant production
lives out to China and the United States
and you know of course we can seek to
buy from abroad but then there won't be
a UK defense and Aerospace industry and
we won't be able to necessarily give our
troops the exact equipment they want so
we have to always make that balance but
you know Ukraine is exposed Supply
chains have been frozen or you know out
of out of out of commission for far too
long we face that challenge Spain
Germany France Italy all the European
countries face that challenge and that's
what that new money is going towards and
that's why it's important to send a
demand signal to Industry to say we are
investing that's what we did with the
Defense command paper in 2020 we'll
continue to do so now finally what is
the danger for UK security if the PM
does not give you the increase in
funding of 3 billion a year the defense
sources say is needed well I I'm not
going to go to the these are dispense
sources first and foremost we have a
comprehensive spending plan that takes
us roughly to the end of 224. we're on
track to continue that investment I
think I think the reality is as I've
always said is we need to modernize our
armed forces and keep Pace but there's
also another thing that we can do in
government which is make sure that we
match our appetite with the size of our
stomach you know we can do lots of
things the British Armed Forces our
armed forces are some of the best in the
world but of course what we mustn't do
is overreach your over promise and try
and do everything for everybody because
that's in the end how you get in
financial problems so I think it's a
it's a two-way discussion how much do
you want to do that's how much it's
going to cost and then we come to an
arrangement well let's see what happens
in the next few weeks and months okay
thank you very much